they've come every year for decades the
Great and Powerful meeting in Munich to
discuss the world security but rarely at
such a crucial moment America's vice
president a former prosecutor was here
with a message and a charge sheet
against Russia's leadership
welcome vice president U.S government
she told the conference believe Russia
is guilty of the gravest of crimes there
is no doubt
these are crimes against humanity
this is a pivotal moment says Britain's
prime minister on the eve of the
anniversary of the invasion and a
possible Russian counter-offensive in
Ukraine Rishi sunak was here to urge
allies to do more we must help Ukraine
to Shield its cities from Russian bombs
and Iranian drones
and that's why the United Kingdom will
be the first country to provide Ukraine
with longer range weapons
there is no shortage of verbal support
for Ukraine
Putin today from this conference Unity
unity and unity
there is a mismatch between the rhetoric
of leaders
and staunch support of Ukraine and the
actual military backing that they are
sending there's a fresh doubt over the
number of modern battle tanks that
allies can actually spare there's a
shortage of ammunition and there's still
no United plan on how or when to send
fighter jets
General David Petraeus one of the great
military minds of our time says allies
know they'll have to send warplanes in
the end to help Ukraine
I I personally believe it's inevitable
that Western aircraft have to be
provided to Ukraine there's no
alternative we're running out of migs
and flankers there may be a few left in
Eastern Europe somewhere that can be
refurbished and provided to Ukraine but
they now have more pilots than they have
aircraft they have to transition to
Western aircraft at some point in time
during the war and they certainly will
after the war is over and hopefully
they're a member of NATO Britain is
training ukrainians to fly fighter jets
and today promise to help other
countries send older planes the
ukrainians are already used to flying
you know these are complicated complex
uh bits of equipment they do need
training and that's what we are doing
and starting that as early as possible
but what we've also said and I said
today is that we will happily provide
assistance to any country that is able
to provide Ukraine with fighter jets
right now the UK strand's ready to
support those countries as well
there is a determination to ramp up
support but this is an alliance of
democracies moving at different speeds
hoping there is still time to deter
Russians offensive
Dominic wagorn Sky News Munich